and maybe this is a good spot for me to
stop and introduce ambassador hall
talking about crisis crisis that is kind
of there and somehow away from our
consciousness right crisis of people
millions of them going to bed with empty
stomachs it's just absolutely incredible
right but that's happening and what's
incredible is that it's difficult to
generate enough interest motivation
enthusiasm to do something about
something that he ought to be able to do
something it ought to be clear right
that it should be think thought of it's
a basic human right not to have to go to
bed with empty stomach right and yet we
don't act as if this fact of millions of
people doing so is the most egregious
violation of human rights as I would say
of any that we are experiencing today
and very little is I think talk about
person who has done quite a bit about it
who's made his life work to do something
about it is ambassador Tony Cole i'm
adding first time i think we were
reminiscing about this in the the hills
of croatia in a small place called fuji
neck where he was participating in group
that was working on reconciliation at
that time and he was said that i'm
living in rome and occasionally would
come to these work workshops with people
from different parts of former
yugoslavia and then i heard his story
and since those
I've been ambassador halls fan he was
three times nominated for nobel prize
and the leading advocate for hunger
relief programs and improving human
rights conditions in the world in
February 202 President George Bush asked
him a Democrat to serve as the United
States ambassador to the United Nations
agencies for food and agriculture and
prior to his diplomatic service he
represented third District of Ohio in
the US Congress for almost 24 for years
the their longest serving representative
in history and much of that time was not
just attending to the interests of his
district but advocating for the poor the
hungry of this world ambassador hall how
are you well thank you miroslav and it's
wonderful to be with you and I it's
great to be here to again talk about a
subject that I care very deeply about
poverty hunger and faith as a matter of
fact I had to go to the Congress of the
United States to find out about faith I
didn't know anything about God actually
I became a believer as a result of being
a member of the Congress of the United
States we could talk about that a little
bit later if you want to it wasn't too
long after I was in the Congress and I I
became a believer and friend of mine
said I've got to introduce Tony to a
group of people and and it was a group
of
all people from around the country and
he got so excited he said now I want to
introduce my friend Tony Hall he's a US
congressman and he's a Christian and
people started to you know kind of
laughing somebody was giggling in the
back and an older man down front he was
looking up at me and he was kind of
squirming in his seat and he just after
a while he couldn't take it much longer
he just hollered up at me said make up
your mind buddy you can't be both today
I wanted to talk a little bit about
what's going on in the world actually
maybe what's going on a little bit in
our own country as we look at around the
world today you know before this day is
up there'll be 25,000 people that will
die and they will die of hunger and
hunger related diseases and yesterday
25,000 people died and tomorrow 25,000
people died and almost half the people
it's it's probably two fifths well
almost half live on less than two
dollars a day and at least a billion
people today are facing malnutrition in
our own country there are 49 million
people that live in what we call food
insecure homes and it's not the kind of
hunger let's say that's like in North
Korea or Ethiopia or or Sudan but it's
the kind of hunger where people in the
united states are going to bed hungry
two or three days out of every month
without eating and these are people
could be senior citizens it could be
women with children matter of fact most
of them are that
and these are people that once they get
done paying for their rent or their
daycare center or their utility bills
they run out of money two or three days
and they find themselves going to food
banks or soup kitchens 49 million we
haven't had those kind of numbers since
nineteen sixty what is what does God
have to say about this well as I read
the scriptures he has a lot to say about
it there's over 2500 verses in the Bible
to deal with this issue and you can't
pick up the Old Testament New Testament
without reading about it I mean miroslav
talked about Matthew 25 but there's
probably not a page and in the scripture
that you can't read about the orphans
and widows the alien women and children
the sick people with leprosy the hurting
the lonely God talks about them
extensively there are some great verses
and proverbs to my verses that I really
like in Proverbs one is in 14 another
one is in 19 it says that and I'm
paraphrasing houses those that that are
gracious to the poor honor God and
another one says those who are gracious
those who are good to the poor those who
work with the poor lend to God I find
that kind of amazing because God doesn't
say that many places that if you do this
if you work with the poor if you help
them you lend to me you honor me
I got involved in this issue it probably
started when I was in the Peace Corps I
was in the Peace Corps for two years and
back in the late 1960s 67 68 but I
really got involved in this issue of
hunger in 1984 when Ethiopia was having
this horrendous famine in in its country
and they had lost a million people
through hunger and what had happened in
Ethiopia is that they were they had
droughts the drought turn in the famine
civil war started the leader of the
country wouldn't let him bunny in the
years country especially humanitarian
workers and Development Assistance
people and and they were kind of locked
out of the country even the press was
not allowed in for about six months and
before we could get in a million people
had died I felt that you know as
chairman at that time I was chairman of
the Subcommittee on international hunger
in the Congress and I felt that how can
a million people die on one country and
I had been reading about it in paper but
I needed to maybe see it walk around in
it smell it try to understand it you
know we read a lot of things and we see
a lot of things but to really I mean and
we see it on television but to really
feel it to understand it I felt that it
was incumbent upon me to take a look and
maybe report back to Congress as to what
I had seen I was not prepared for it and
I went to Ethiopia and I went with
mother teresa's group sisters of charity
and we were up above the capital addis
ababa about two hours and by light plane
we were we were in a very rural area and
we were to visit this clinic for the
clinic was probably no bigger than this
room and it was in the middle of nowhere
and apparently a lot of Ethiopians it
was
on top of a plateau had been walking for
miles some well over 100 miles they sold
everything to get there some had walked
well over a hundred miles they thought
that there was going to be blankets and
water food medicines and there was
nothing except this little clinic that
at best could marry maybe serve five
people that day that a couple nuns had
one doctor that was visiting and when I
walked into the compound I noticed there
were just thousands of people
surrounding this clinic soon as I walked
in that dr. grabbed me he said come with
me outside I got to show you something
because we can handle maybe five
children out there that are dehydrated
and the rest are in trouble and there
must have been at least among children
three thousand children so I went
outside with him and they thought I was
a doctor and you know the mothers are
handing me in some cases they're dead
children and in a matter of minutes I
probably saw 25 children die I never got
over that I think about that often and
it was just one child after another
dying of dehydration and you know what
happens when you haven't eaten for a
while your immune system goes down when
your immune system goes down you're very
susceptible to all kinds of diseases
that can come in and they were just
dying at alarming rates and to see 25
Joe children die in a matter of minutes
was it I was stunned I and for the next
three days in Ethiopia that's all I saw
this tremendous amount of death and I
never got over that I remember coming
back on the plane and thinking that you
know we do a lot of things in Congress
really that don't amount to much and I
wanted to make my life count
and this is what I was going to do i was
going to start working on hunger and I
had remembered before I was going over
there I had a young man who was about my
age that came in it was kind of a mentor
mine and and I was as I had told you
I've as a young believer a young person
that believed in the Lord and I was
studying and praying and and he said
after wow he said this was prior to
going on this trip you said don't you
think it's time to bring God into your
workplace and I said well how do you do
that I said you know I don't want to be
a hypocrite I don't I don't really like
politicians that you know where religion
on their on their lapel and try to shove
it down people's throats because that's
a real turn off it's hypocritical and
I'd rather see a sermon then here one
but I know what you're talking about I
know that I do need to bring faith into
my workplace but I want to do it in a
way and which is it is comfortable to me
so as I went to Ethiopia as I had seen
this tremendous amount of death as it
began to read the scriptures about how
much God really talks about the 2500
verse is about the poor and the sick I
thought this is a way that I can bring
my faith into my work place and not
shove it down people's throat I don't
have to tell anybody all i have to do is
just do it and hopefully my faith will
speak a voice of its own so i began to
travel and eventually I became chairman
of the committee and of the whole
committee and that included domestic
hunger and an international hunger and I
ended up going to about 130 nations
traveling so many different places we
legislated passed a lot of laws that are
in that have been in law for a number of
years and and
what happened was that I became so
involved in this issue that I began to
get letters and phone calls from my
district in Dayton Ohio saying you know
congressman we think that you think more
about Ethiopia or Africa or Asia than
you do about they know how who needs you
you need to come home and think about
Dayton Ohio there was a perception that
I was thinking more international than I
was my own district it wasn't a true
perception but in politics perception is
a lot and people have a perception about
you it's you either better change it or
you're going to get stuck with that
perception so I got my my staff together
and I said look there's this perception
we need to change it I love this issue I
don't want to lose this issue because I
could lose my office here I said let's
let's bring this issue back home to Ohio
and let's let's educate my constituency
let's do some things back here and let's
find out what's going on here in Dayton
Ohio and the suburbs and things in South
in southwest Ohio which we did and we
started a gleaning program you know a
gleaning program is a is you know where
you go into the fields and you pick the
produce that's not picked by farmers you
know there's a hundred and ten million
tons of food every year that goes to
waste in this country 110 million tons
it wastes in the fields it doesn't get
picked or it wastes and grocery stores
are on the way to the wholesaler or we
wasted in our own homes we have to throw
it out 110 million tons so we decided
through churches and various Jewish
groups secular groups that we would go
out at harvest time and we would find
some farmers that really wanted to help
us and we had all we had so much food
it was unbelievable and we did this for
about 15 years we had gleaning programs
at harvest time that picked up fruits
and vegetables and just had so much food
we didn't know what to do with it but we
had a system where we gathered it and
took took it to a central warehouse and
I had 66 food banks and soup kitchens
than the word went out today we got
strawberries tomorrow we got apples now
we got whatever whatever was corn
whatever was being harvested in Ohio at
the time which was a lot of food and
then we started as senior citizen
feeding program on the weekends during
the cold winter months when a lot of
them are shut in that lasted about 20
years and then we did a immunization
program for kids and we did a pickup of
food programs from country clubs and
rest in restaurants and motels and and I
had a huge military base in my in my
backyard that we gathered and we got the
people involved because I felt that I
had to bring the issue back home because
I felt it's incumbent upon elected
officials to educate your district you
know sometimes elected a lectin
officials you know not sometimes they
should lead and not wait for the wind to
change it's a coming upon them to lead
and to educate and to and to direct
prior what I had first got elected I did
a poll in my district because I wanted
to know how my people felt about issues
I said you know so we listed a number of
issues the deficit they jobs whatever
the issues were in those days the budget
taxes environment etc poverty hunger and
I said ranked his issues well hunger
poverty ranked glass out of 15 I think
it was 15 or 20 issues ranked last we
did these programs and before I left
office after 24 years I did this pole
again same poll asked the same questions
hunger ranked number two so you can
change your constituents minds and you
can change for good and you can bring an
issue back home and make things happen
and that was really very very exciting
to me I right now I run up nonprofit
organization in Washington DC it's
called the Alliance to end hunger and
it's a little organization we're growing
and what we do is we build political
will we do a number of things we I
believe that hunger poverty development
assistance but especially the issue of
hunger the only way to solve it if
you've got to bring everybody into the
room it's not just government this
belongs to private enterprise it belongs
to the people of faith and it belongs to
the nonprofit's so our organization has
corporations large corporations from
cargill to land of lakes to other
corporations to the Catholic Relief
Services to world vision to save the
children to and then on the religious
side the faith-based we have the Islamic
Relief a lot of Christians are Christian
churches and two major Jewish
organizations so we bring everybody into
the room and we work on creating
political will we do that in a number of
ways we do polling we work on
corporations meet working with nonprofit
organizations overseas in our own
country we we build national alliances
in other countries especially in poor
nations you know I spent a lot of time
with congressmen and Senators trying to
get them to do things to be better men
and women for this issue talking to them
about this issue sometimes lobbying them
and we're doing what's going to start
doing the same thing in other countries
in poor nations because working with
civil society it's you know some of the
some of the civil society and very poor
nations for them to learn how to lobby
and for them to be advocates is
something very new to them so we're
teaching them we're teaching civil
society how to how to advocate and then
the other thing I'm trying to reconnect
and we've started this congressmen and
senators and governors and mayors back
to their district about hunger so they
can have hunger free communities and I'm
sick and tired of elected officials just
running to be reelected I want them to
be leaders again I want them to be
interested in this issue this issue is
if it's if it's not in the top five
issues of our world today I don't know
what isn't and as we pull on this issue
it's it's it's one of the top two or
three issues always with the American
people the American people are way ahead
of our elected officials on this issue
so what I'm going to do or what I am
trying to do is get the the congressmen
and Senators to go back to the district
get acquainted with their food bank
people their faith based people there
their corporations and call a meeting
and we have a 14-point program that we
really started back when I was a
congressman and chairman of the
committee that we are asking them to in
some districts around the country to
start doing hunger-free communities that
what would it take to make your district
hunger-free and if you could be able to
say to your people that nobody's going
to go to bed hungry again in my district
and you imagine what that would do for
the morale the economics I think people
would want to live there I think
corporal races would want to invest
there so we're going to
we're going to take congressmen senators
and Mara get them reacquainted with
their district especially the hunger
areas and we're trying to build hunger
heroes that's pretty much what the
alliance to end hunger does I'm the
executive director of it and that's what
i do now in conclusion I just want to
say that there's a lot of overwhelming
things going on in the world today when
it comes to hunger and poverty but I had
the great chance to be with Mother
Teresa number of times in my lifetime I
even went to her funeral but I remember
the first time I met her in Calcutta
first when I met her she grabbed my hand
and she said five things to me it was
pretty much what miroslav said she
quoted right for Matthew 25 she said
never forget never forget she grabbed
each one of my fingers for the least of
these for the least of these that's five
that's a five words she said to me then
she took me downtown in Calcutta we went
to this place I can't remember exactly
where it was but it was in such a
congested part of Calcutta that people
were living on the sidewalk and sleeping
on the street I mean it just it was
overrun with people and I'm thinking I'm
chairman of the Select Committee and
hunger and I must have blurted out
something to her to Mother Teresa I said
look at this I mean I'm supposed to be
chairman of the hunger committee I'm not
even sure I can handle this block with
all these people here she said where do
you start and she she didn't say
anything and she went and there was a
man lying in the street she got some men
to pick him up take him home to her to
her
hospice like place and she began to wash
him off and love him and hug him like
she always does and she came back to me
later in the afternoon and she said kind
of task answer my question she said do
the thing it's in front of you she said
you can't always not everybody like you
can come to Calcutta but if everybody
did the things in front of him what's
going on in New Haven what's going on in
Boise Idaho what's going on in dayton
ohio if everybody did the thing that's
in front of do the thing it's in front
of you probably half the stuff we do in
Congress who wouldn't need so that was
her point to me and that's my point to
you just do the thing that's in front of
you okay good to talk to you